the first speaker today is Bart Tillman
because I'm an automated scientific
discovery using in central problem ok
thank you I'm so yeah so this is joint
work with with Scala Gomes Ron and
LeBron now at the Paul Paul Ellen
Institute in Seattle the eye institute
Stephan Stephan El hermana currently
extend an outstanding Asian shoe who
will finish up next year in our group so
oops so the work started bye bye you
know I've done a lot of work on
influence a lot of work on
satisfiability solvers and we want to
use these tools for for scientific
discovery and yeah partly motivated that
that's sort of one of the key
outstanding challenges in AI but it's
also a very interesting problem so so
i'll be talking today mainly about
working we didn't in finite and discrete
math finite mathematics with other work
in mature a little more practical and
materials discovering where we where we
synthesize new materials for fuel cells
and for renewable energy but i actually
won't one cover that just to not be too
long soaps so in the early day is
actually of autumn a theorem proving
there was a lot of optimism about you
know actually just first order logic
theorem provers so so in the 1960s when
resolution was discovered first
automated techniques for first-order
logic inference the idea was that we
soon would be proving interesting
theorems and mathematics just by
translating to first order logic and
running the solvers it is actually was
this pointing i guess so people
discovered it really it really doesn't
work the language first logic
in a certain sense is too powerful but
you might not think if you're logician
don't think first it was too powerful
but for a inference procedure it's too
powerful to general so if you look at
even proving simple theorems in about
number theory or something like that
basic here is it that humans proved
easily if you're improvers cannot do yet
may still take a long time if you look
at total adidas what goes wrong is this
the search space is too uncle strains do
so your first order logic improver will
search part of the search basement
resolution that has nothing to do with
your theory more will not get you at all
to worship theorem so it doesn't work
okay and then two people maybe 20-30
years to realize what the issue was and
yeah sorry actually so what we actually
show what did become successful is
satisfiability so often propositional
reasoning because it's somewhat more
constraint and the language is more
constrained in the search space is
easier to handle okay I'll just give you
a quick mention of some of the things
that were discovered wasn't the total
failures or some things were very
interesting and and answer that that's
that's one thing I'll talk about briefly
I'll also stress that we're interested
in true discovery in essence of
discovering a new theory Manu result
there's quite a bit of work on improving
community on interactive theorem proving
or proving theory proving theorems that
are known it's hard to judge for me it's
hard to judge that work because you know
things get engineered into the solving
procedure to to get you to the result so
to say it's automatically discovered
this or that becomes hard to judge if
you find something new what we'll do
here we couldn't build it in because we
didn't know what it was looking for so
good
this is new to me and very like
discovering new crimes big crimes that
call automatico discovering new primes I
guess you could call that new so yeah so
I mean it's a spectrum well sort of you
know more towards calculation and known
procedures and I would say its discovery
but not as surprising two words like you
know proving an open theory group theory
or something yet so you probably get to
this but previously unknown interesting
results interesting yes yeah yeah and
again interesting is on the scale of how
interesting you could even judge yeah
yeah we hope to make it very interesting
but of course it's not easy so here just
just going back memory lane well so 1976
they sort of the first wheel I think
computer proof where computers were used
to prove an interesting open problem the
four color theorem of calling planar map
is for colouring callers I'm
characterizing and this is a very rough
characterization so girl you know how yo
how you saw was the computer in that
setting and you know I made up these
numbers so I you know Hagen was was an
apple way they were specialists in the
area and they actually build on previous
proof techniques and in the end they
ended up rioja using the machine to do
basically analyze saying it about two
thousand special sup maps okay but
what's up maps they had to analyze that
was invented by them so or even by
previous people so so the Machine get
some work but it was sort of approved by
cases and sort of almost a checking kind
of thing it was very quite controversial
post still controversial in the mass
world with them at its world it's
accepted it has been replicated it sits
in it's not elegant from the mass
perspective because the you know that
2,000 cases don't give any further
insights about why the theorem is true
and we still don't know
we still don't have a more profound
proof also it had to be done several
times because even though the program's
checking the cases would technically
have to be proofed correct himself and
that's that's never actually done i
think although it's not being replicated
I thinking needs right to see improver
so so now it's being replicated but
there's sort of various problems is that
and then says that when you program says
this this is correct you know do you
know your program is correct okay so
there's several drawbacks and you have
to deal with but overall I would say it
still wasn't was an example of of
automated theorem proving it to prove
something interesting more a little bit
more obscure 1996 Romans algebra showing
that a certain set of actions that was
proposed for for boolean algebras was
complete this was actually a oops I
think more interesting from from a
computational perspective this was
really only about thirty percent human
seventy percent machine very clever
rewriting of actions and and you know
mathematician I have actually worked on
exactly a strategy for many years and
couldn't find how to do that and what's
interesting is that that the de final
theory the final proof is is actually
sort of a one-page proof of the
intermediate steps and it can in
principle you can follow it as a
mathematician that these are the correct
proves to take the correct steps to take
does it provide insides in the overall
theme it's a little more arguable sort
of a magic thing that if you do these
rewrites you get to the you complete
your proof but it is semi human readable
as I say so that was it was a bit of an
advance next one this is a very reason
one and I actually find it quite
exciting if you you want to dig into
this area you shouldn't you look this
one up you might have read about it a
gross discourtesy problem so very very
easy to state we have a sequence of Plus
Ones minus one that goes
I'm very long and you start looking at
the summation of the secret so the
simple summation is just a sequence
itself plus 1 to 12 it goes up and down
if you sum them up and you keep track of
that sub ok now that somebody tells not
so interesting so you start looking at
sub sequences of the sequence so we've
stepped starting by 246 you sum over
that sub sequence then you do the
subsequence 369 all arithmetic
progressions as sub sequences and again
you look at how high up and down does
that sum go ok so what air does propose
or they're just conjecture was that that
if you make this sequence long in US
there's no way to keep the bounds to
keep it between you know sir let's say
plus 2 or minus 2 ok at some point it
will burst out of that bound and in fact
the general conjectures it will get if
you go out very long now all sub
sequences at some point are each there
will always be some sub sequence that
breaks out of the bounds did you
quantifiers out for every infinite
sequence there exists a subsequence that
the samsung bout it yes yes yes it you
you should be up there I guess exactly
exactly so what's surprising about this
at least to me you are surprising
verdict for the bounds of 1 plus 1 and
minus 1 you connect by hand find I think
you can't go beyond 6 I guess then 7 is
already it's a problem for the bottle of
plus 2 minus 2 it was open ok it was
open until two years ago and it was
actually a polymath project by people
your amateur mathematician but real
mathematicians searching even to answer
the question for 2 and part of the
problem with with plus 2 minus 2 is that
you can start looking for sequences that
work and people found surprisingly long
sequences they found signatures of 100
200 300 and they use computer code
programs to search they couldn't find a
violating sequence ok so it actually
stopped
around two thousand twelve people so I
said well we can make real progress they
made some progress a lot of interesting
workers done the building on previous on
different types of sequences from coding
theory that have special properties
about discover see you know this kind of
sequences are interesting for coding
theory to keep you how how regular or
has pseudo-random chemical structure
sequence if that satisfies that keep the
discovery low that's what you want to
have but anyways what some stuff until
somebody this was in acid this is just a
statement okay yeah so this is until I
think the year 2014 okay lychee lisitsa
and colder and colder satisfiability
problem and just downloaded a SAT solver
and they found that if the sequence that
you have to go quite long 1161 is that
is the first sequence so that there
always exists a subsequence that goes
out of bounds in fact they also found
the secret of 1160 elements that stays
within the bound so for the case of a
discovery of two it was just really
really was well in 2014 by a SAT solver
and this work you know i would say it
took him a meal two weeks i actually
replicated it on my mac it's not a
homework assignment to my course it runs
in two hours you can find this seek or
actually one hours and macbook pro you
find this sequence in 10 hours you prove
that no longer one exists okay and and
it took i would say it took the cell
soldiers that were developed above two
or three years ago it's not it really is
just possible okay let me see this is
like so actually coding is fairly sure i
wouldn't that would barely it's barely
ten percent human okay what i find
really interesting about this result is
again it's this case that no longer
subsequence exists because basically
what you're we're going to show you this
sequence in a moment but this result
saying no it is one of these case where
you're running your theorem prover 4 10
hour it's about 10 hours and this year I
see controversia and it will just print
out unset
okay which unsatisfiable meaning i
cannot find a sequence of seizures in
the bounce it's somewhat unsatisfactory
because what if there's a bug in your
program or you saw was actually hugely
complex nowadays you know thousands of
lines of code so you don't really know
what's nice here is it will print out
the proof trace now you might say 13
gigabyte is a little long but that's all
the old school thinking these steps are
very simple so so these are just a
implies be given a next line be now be
in place and see implies D next to you
know every step is a simple modus ponens
eps of the previous of some previous
steps super simple so you can actually
write your own proof checker or you can
download one which is like 20 30 lines
of code download the proof and you check
every step and you'll be convinced I
think that's a reasonably secure and
like a reasonably certain real proof so
it's no longer you have to church again
forget about how that the improver found
that proof and without the sauce over
you could never find it but once you
have that proven you can actually
download it from their website you can
check it yeah it's the question of
hierarchy because maybe now I need to
check the proof check out maybe it's not
a simple proof chicken and then I will
have to check you next one in silver
yeah in terms of the proof checks yeah
yeah so and in this case an approved egg
is really like 20 lines of code but yeah
it can become more intrigued yeah yeah
so but I think it's an important step
for people thinking of using SAT soul
forsythia improvement you don't have to
you don't have to say in the end like
all you have to trust my SATs over you
know yeah that's over out here's the
proof write your own checker and do it
so yeah so for proofing 1161 does not
exist one variables
for every yeah are we setting so 2 to
the 1161 sequences are carefully checked
yeah and and of course you guys I Tom
one class to suit 1161 is 10 to the 350
that's not being done how many how many
inference steps it takes is about 10
billion tend to the 10 10 to the 11th
this is also the one that tau soft right
I'll come to that yes yeah yeah because
yeah so there wasn't anything on trivial
done with the encoding to set it was
faithful very straightforward to very
store yeah that's not an issue that you
have to formulate that encoding so there
you also want to be sure that that
encoding is very transparent yes and
that's important yeah and and yeah so
yeah so Terrence that so afternoons was
done so Tara found was involved in the
original polymath project there are some
other things that came out of this work
about multiplicative sub sequences and
special kinds of sequences and Tara
style you know a year later used a very
deep results which I find too hard to
explain from another area to actually
prove the general conjecture so he
cleaned up the area and said okay now
the full conjectures proved so that's an
amazing result I still think that that
was partly the multiple give a
substitution won't discuss was was
discovered in this type of work so so I
think there's a used a little bit of
those insights but did much deeper bass
much more general so but still this was
the first one for the cases too okay
which was surprised it was open so so
yeah actually yeah let me actually show
you so let me so what I'm saying so each
of results i just mentioned inside you
know get some insight in underlying
problem structure of the domain but but
there's still work to be done and and
what my talk is about here is you know
we find this complex object so let's say
there are two issues why is if the
sequence exists can you actually
understand what is the structure of the
particular solution what is what is
underlying the structure
so I'll show you that sequence in the
moment yeah can we describe it so that's
what this talk is about the other side
will be to take that 14 or 18 gigabyte
proof and understand the structure of
that proof that's another problem and I
want to talk about but I think it's very
exciting I think there is structuring
that proof and we probably can
understand it and we can discover new
mass if we start understanding analyzing
these proofs okay here's the thing so
here's the 1160 sequence and all I want
to stress about it so if you if you look
at all the subsequent over some
everything stays in two so and this is
the longest possible and and so in
general and what what am I going to talk
about this you know I'd like to
understand this better now we don't
understand this one better because it's
we just start looking at that one and it
was only recently discovered but but but
there presumably is some structure here
that would actually allow is that for
examples computer scientists to find a
little constructive procedure to
generate the sequence we just don't know
what it is okay um yeah so is a
subsequence this is means you have start
from the beginning and just do every
second or every third it's not like yes
nah intervals four subintervals
ourselves you know pieces within the
overall sequence no no no it's it's
starting literally starting at the
beginning so the substance toughest two
starts at two four six and these are
homogeneous arithmetic expression like
that it also counts as a subsidy yeah
yeah yeah yeah no actually 135 chef no
no it actually has it has to start
memorial starting at zero starting at
zero yeah yeah so homogeneous there's
actually results on these other kind of
sub sequence and actually I think it's a
result of slightly easier to prove for
this is the hard case the other ones are
easier to obtain
okay so you know just if you say well
you know what's this talk about this
it's about yeah moving beyond you know
just getting solutions and witnesses try
to find a structure in those witnesses
and we were able to do that for an other
type of problem and I just have to
introduce that it's got the spatially
letter balance Latin square problem it's
it's yo coloring problem or this is an
application table of a quazy group and
we have six different callers and what
we want is we wanted you know no
repetition of colors in any row or in
any column that gives us a quazy group a
multiplication grab of quadruped are
just a lot and square but we have one
more coming so constructing does is easy
closet groups you can generate easily so
it's a very nice results and Markov
chains that generates sample from crazy
groups but we have a much tougher
constraint here average column wise pair
of cymbals okay it has a balanced
structure let me show you the next slide
because it's easy it's clear okay here
so here's a spatially balanced left and
square for 260 it's 11 square so every
call if you would check carefully
there's no repetition in any color in
row of any color to the row or column
okay that's that's the first thing
that's that's the easy thing to do the
second thing is much harder so we're
looking at every pair so I have a few
pairs of callers but opus or pairs are
up here but they're just a few example
red and green and for each row right the
distance down okay just there next to
each other this is one we call this one
these are for apart there's three in
between so for part 2 part 3 access a
week we write for this in every row we
write down the distance of this pair we
add them up and we get and you can
divide it by the number of rows you get
an average distance okay if you can also
just look at the Sun okay now let's
remarkable about these constructions you
look for every coloring pair and you add
up these guys they have to add up to the
same number
this gives you all added up to 14 okay
so they're carefully balanced in terms
of the average distance of all possible
colors pair of callers okay now you
might say why why do you care about this
well this is part of the other problem k
match the color gomes actually
completions 10 building got this problem
from people working in agriculture doing
doing we have it yeah new york state to
test fertilizers they run experiments on
different plots of lands and to do these
experiments you want to limit the court
you want to take away you know you want
to deal with correlations as well as
possible and so you want to actually
sort of have the different experiments
at different distances all possible
differences in a balanced way so it's
part of what's called the field of
experimental design and so it leads to
these very hard you know material design
problems to run an actual experiment on
virtualizes or whatever kind of sub
disco sperm you want to do as our takes
care of correlations properly okay so
six five six or seven actually I think
my Carla got involved this was also the
largest known one okay it's not easy to
find when these were found just what was
this is what I think you can still find
by hand don't don't ask me how they
found it it's a tough one but Carly got
involved in actually generating them so
so here you know when she got involved
in I guess 2.4 there's another selman
you see it slightly misspelled but but
it's good for my scholar count okay so
and yeah it's a constraint programming
we hired them as opposed to get was
quite confusing so order nine they found
absolutely I think she could say busy as
a search problem and this is a local
search poem you see it going up a bit
and then the time was fast and now
streamlining I'm going to get to that
composition by streamlining and the
large they could do streamlined local
search a very specialized kind of local
storage they could do order 35 35 x 35
and 1.2 million second
that's sort of where they stopped and
said well so we can find some of these
larger what it actually some there's
actually a little starter kittens as
weird this little startup company
actually selling these designs now 35
yeah 35 yeah yeah every role has to be
uniquely yeah yeah yeah so all the calls
and then we just use numbers I guess
yeah so with its air conditioned and
what is now known is that for certain
orders you can prove it doesn't exist
and we have what will get you its
construction that for other orders we
can actually construct it now I'm giving
away two main pointer yeah yeah yeah
yeah so a lot more we've known now okay
so uh yeah so 300 hours of CPS so this
was the solution 330 hours of CPU time
completely balanced well of 11 square
and we'll say hope it verified that and
now so here now we can generate guys
like this number a millisecond this is
what it's talking about so we can do we
are 10 k by 10k in a few seconds so so
now we can just generate whatever we
want for certain not for all artists
which were sort of orders with some
properties but we can go our very large
and and so but just to go back you know
when we saw this yeah we said well there
has to be something about this these
problems and actually my client and yet
is like things like like Ramsey numbers
and all these kind of interesting poems
from from discrete finite mathematics we
believe that video that there are
constructions for the cases when the
objects exist we just don't know what
the constructions are it's it's you know
it's hidden in solutions now when people
use SAT solvers they just get solutions
like this and then they say okay we're
done okay we wanted to take the next
step what is the construction underlying
us
probabilistic to any constructive and a
constructive yeah we want to want to get
to the constructive part yeah and anyhow
first before we said we know it exists
that so but yeah so so how do you find
it and constructive summer to construct
something like this so okay okay so um
so we've done the motivation okay so now
let me show how we found the
construction so because that's I think
the interesting part so discovering
problem structure in discovering you
know as it actually problem solution
structure were interested in the
solutions of the problem and whether
there's hidden structure in there and
the key tool that we use this is
something that was used in sat solving
and in automated reasoning it's called a
tool that's called streamlining so the
key behind a lot of efficient reasoning
why are the sets hoping so so powerful
is the propagation mechanism it's it's
sort of you know you said the view
variables that propagate true your
formula then there is things like claws
learning where you add inferred
constraints during your search and you
get more propagation so i think but i
would say ninety percent or maybe even
ninety-five percent of all the work is
done by very fast unit propagation the
problem is you want to increase that
propagation so the conservative way of
increasing the propagation is just to
learn these new clauses and and hope
that you get more propagation works very
well that's why we're going to milling
variable problems in Hardware
verification software verification on
but streamlining textures that step
further we're going to add constraints
and we're going to cut parts of the
search pays off that those parts might
have all the solutions in which case we
we streamline to the wrong subproblem
but we're hoping that the streamlining
these extra constraints are going to
guide us to areas of the search base
with very regular solutions and we hope
to find those so let me
so so we actually so the general claim
here is when you do this kind of search
comin torial search you know the
tendencies we want to keep all possible
solutions around we want to be
conservative what we're going to be here
is non-conserved you're going to say
keeping the full solution sets hiddenly
michael strains and keep looking for
that might actually be very may be too
hard and we'll actually see that in this
case that's too hard so we're actually
going to cut down yeah 1160 solution
that you mentioned be unique for we look
for the link yeah that's not unique yeah
yeah yeah so does she not solution is
unique like you're searching the wrong
direction on you then you lose very
quickly 50 the way zeagle of solutions
then then you go wrong yeah yeah so well
actually although you know the process
we're going to do is very incremental so
so we have to start in small instances
so we would show to the way although i'm
not going to show it on the undie
describe see problem guess we haven't
done that yet but we would start with
smaller seem like secret of 400 try to
generate my question is do you think
he's gonna walk even when the solution
is unique or extensive solution and
therefore if you guided you still gonna
find something yeah so the structure I'm
giving is actually is exactly it takes
care of that we're going to do this
incrementally going to larger and larger
size so even a solution comes unique
which it isn't quite for the airless one
but even if it would be unique this
strategy still works yeah so yeah very
good problem so okay let me just so I
think we have so with the way I look at
it is you know for integrated coming to
our problems if solution exists it will
often be some highly regular one can we
find those and can we get our search
algorithm to find those okay that's
that's the key thing and so this is
streamlined search overview sorry so you
start with you know so it's go sexually
very simple idea but but it's
surprisingly powerful you start with
your original solution like you tuned to
the 1160 or some of that huge space but
you start asserting some condition some
constraint on that solution space like
and like you might have concerns that
cuts up this little part and say I'm
only going to look for solution
especially building square that are
symmetrical for example they're pretty
simple strange now you're searching in
the Subspace okay and of course your
hope is I have to do this process so
that that I keep having solutions in
these subspaces yeah okay um okay I love
me okay a circle is called that we call
the streamliner and it's a foreskin yeah
and the streamlined condition is
maintained during the search as a set of
constraints and unit propagation handles
it enforces its quickly so it also has
to be fast okay there's actually quite a
bit of work how do you define a
streamline as well your insights I used
a lot but we want to actually move more
to machine learning and actually some
claws learning inset so one can actually
be viewed as findings from streamliners
so it's it's yeah these are too abstract
to really make much sense of so let me
skip over these yeah let me just get to
that I'm also going to skip over there
so we have a general framework to find
stream wise but it's much easier just to
see a little example so what we're doing
at the high levels we start with this is
a set of streamlines initially empty and
we we start with small instances let's
say and it's order 3 3 by 3 or 4 by 4
and generate stuber's lowest order and
we generate solutions let me see where
that comes up here we generate solutions
okay and then we look at these solutions
or if we have a machine learning
approach we we look for regularity it's
using using using some machine learning
matter that looks for for for
statistical regularities we get our
solution set we find some regularities
and we conjecture that there are
solutions with those regularity and we
assert it to the solver okay then we
strengthen this set so let's say now
each other let's say we found symmetries
in these solutions okay doesn't have to
be all so here's the subset of solutions
has symmetries okay maybe symmetries is
is some to enforce so enforce it and we
strengthen it now we go to a larger size
okay and we try to solve this one we get
other solutions find new streamliners
keep going now we might now and then
assert if you actually saw symmetric and
cyclic which is sort of like rotating
the columns if you do them together you
actually you know you don't get any
solutions I think size six so there you
have the weekend you have to throw out
and we actually I think it later on we
throw out actually cyclic but here which
are out symmetric so that's set of
constraints actually grows in strength
grows and shrink okay okay the key point
is the next one so we have a whole setup
where people explore and this is what
would run and LeBrock implemented and
the beautiful system where you can
interact and here you can actually you
get example solutions here you can
assert streamliners based on what you
see and then you go to next size and
generate bigger ones okay I think what's
most interesting is that is the the
finals so is this table here so because
this shows sort of what the real process
is so if you don't assert any structure
and no streamliners you can do up to
size 6 we actually went fairly 60
seconds but we could you know even even
if you do hours you can't find these
kinds of lucius at all so so the
actually you come to your search can
just get to this okay but you start
looking at these kinds of solutions and
UC solutions that are symmetric ok so
you assert that you get your new set of
streamliners ok now you can suddenly
generate so you're going to help your
solver because you're going to find
different higher instances and they're
going to have this symmetric structure
and you look at those instances and now
i won't go into the reduce means one of
the combs is fixed in order 1 2 3 4 5 6
up to
actually the left column and the top row
you start finding more and more
structure than you you assert that new
structure and you can you can you know
you can generate some more it's like in
this case you don't actually solve new
ones but we actually get new insights
we're focusing on a subset of solutions
okay look at it does resolution you you
assert those properties and you can
solve a little bigger okay then he's
found one final properties and I'm not
explaining these properties in the paper
but these are interesting properties and
suddenly you can get up to sue size 14
okay so so two things that are so
important you can only find a larger
usually couldn't find largest solutions
if you didn't assert your initial
structure so you know the streamlines
helped us over okay there's a human in
the loop but for this one is a loop
human let me now we're now working Oh
any structure yeah you have to you have
to stare at him a little bit yeah but
we're working on automating it so that's
that's the that's the next step but I
think it actually is doable so so it
actually to this refers to your comment
if you pick an armchair so so if I had
to go back probably not a good idea but
if I do very quickly
if I look at this guy there is no way
you're going to see the structure this
is a sort of almost a random solution
one of the solutions are the sites of a
[ __ ] I guess the door maybe they are so
this is a reckless you couldn't actually
find a structure in this problem so so
one thing we are arguing here is you
have to do this extra mentally because
you have to focus in on a special subset
of solutions and if you do it step by
step you will be guided to these special
and if you look at keV let the details
of these solutions you will find to
structuring them and but if it has to be
done incrementally okay so streamline
reveals new general it so when you use
the system you actually have to go this
is sort of what mathematicians do of
course they go small is as large as
large inches it's a very natural process
but you actually have to go to that and
then finally but with us yeah at size 14
yo you get you see enough structure in
your solutions that you actually can
look at is there a constructive
procedure okay and yes that size-14
that's that's happening and I think it's
best to look at this at this one so it
has an example of a size 14 construction
with all these streamliners and you
start seeing things I so this is
asserted actually these are the regular
structure to certain 12 to 14 the rotor
Brown in a coma is sorted you can look
at you can check the symmetry is there
everything but what's more interesting
is you start seeing some structuring
house gets in this Cove let's see so 246
a so this goes two steps of two up to 14
and then it goes 13 11 9 goes down you
see so the month on the increasing layer
by constant steps and then goes down
okay similarly this goes up steps of
three then goes down 14 11 8 then goes
up again 55 and then it goes to then 14
it goes up again you see these sort of
sub sequences with constant differences
although the second oh I steps are to
the surplus three steps of four it gets
a little messy because you quickly get
over you have steps of 5 5 10
you go 15 so you're a too high so
something so she becomes shorter and
shorter but you can sort of generalize
you say wait a minute maybe we can a
construction that starts creating the
sub sequences and then you know when it
goes over n you go do subsections down
okay so and that actually is the
procedure ok this is the it's actually
not hard to take this and generalize it
and actually come up with with a little
constructive procedure that will now
generate patterns like this and of
course for for objects that have to come
to Strangeland size 2 n plus 1 has to be
prime ok so it doesn't work for all
orders but for any end where you know
order n where 2 n plus 1 is prime it
will generate it and now you can do the
next step you can prove it correct and
that's a that's a mess approve but it
can be done ok so now you have a
construction of this object and and
again it's not it's not fully automatic
but but it the search to come to your
research in the streamlining is
essential get the structure out and
we're not trying to integrate with more
machine learning to to conjecture stream
whiners that's what you want to do and
do it more automatic we have 14 that
does that does a cyclic one I remember
actually to add the cyclical strained
early on but you can do the same game in
the cichlid one and now the sequences
are going vertically that's a second
procedure to do it so ok and this is
pretty much actually so in command
approach in terms of size is necessarily
need to reveal the structure by
increasingly larger so if you start two
large you won't find in a structure in
the solution true solution comes visible
at some point and and you know and and
answer the streamlining is needed to
even generate solutions otherwise you
couldn't get any solutions actually so
we actually could you know conjecture
that many comparisons from have affected
yet to be discovered construction
procedure Kwazii group it's just those
forms co-design ramsey grass as a young
Erdos like I think that's an interesting
anecdote how we never will know certain
running numbers I actually don't believe
it I think we will find constructive
procedure doing this kind of work so
very intricate procedures but still
constructive but there's still some
things our own now read like busy beever
numbers there will be some things we
don't know yes there will be something
buddy yeah Oh general congestion assume
that i have a small description so i
have the formula there exists an X such
as phi of x + 5 short exists of X less
than T yeah does it imply that I will be
able to generate such an example in size
which is not exponential in T yeah I
mean this is I mean these are general
swatches yeah very small description
yeah yeah and then you want to generate
and a witness witness of this formula
with in time which is not exhaustive
search yeah now is there hope for such a
theorem it's whenever you have a small
description there exist and to generate
some exponential time in the next yeah
yeah that would be incredible we don't
know yeah we don't know no because I aid
the small description
you add the requirement that the region
small discussion oh but yeah so there is
a very interesting action of how many
things can we do this and yeah and what
are the limits on it yeah so okay that's
all right so yeah so I think you know
that's you know this is yeah I'm just
conjecturing here that for certain thing
and we've actually done work on shore
numbers and and some other work has been
done from the word in numbers so I think
definitely in certain areas but probably
not at all we can find these procedures
that's the conjecture so you know it's
pushing going a little bit thing sets
over the crusher they're all these
reasoning thing we want to move from the
per instance base where generally we
stopped when we find some solution for
some size we want to go and say okay
what is the general structure of the
solution space can we can we identify
subset that we can construct new low bar
new algorithms you know we're sort of
hoping that maybe we can find
interesting new algorithms by pushing
this kind of you know interactive design
of a procedure and I think there's not
much more so yes as I said we did some
sure numbers graceful grasp you know
very strange come to Tori objects but we
can we can find them so overall the work
shows of this dis streamlining approach
that's a different kind of approach to
combinatorial search where you say I
can't and no way are going to search you
know 10 to the CL of you to 60 binary
subsequence all these Latin squares of
all possible range you can't search the
whole space but I'm gonna search in a
subspace a subspace that has some
interesting structure and we see
actually current SAT solvers I find that
quite interesting are starting to use
things like satisfiability preserving
steps but not solution for service they
don't suspect they don't keep exactly a
set of solutions around they just say
you know if my previous in my brief
instance is satisfiable I do a
transformation guarantees is still
satisfiable if the reason one was but
they can have more
solutions for example or fewer solutions
and that's use right now during the
search process not just as a
pre-processing even during the search
process so this is becoming more more
effective so we firmly streamlined six
most promising most structured bicycle
your space ideally allows for much
deeper searches you can go much farther
out and and we're starting to discover
them automatically and he says ok thanks
ok so my shins are you talking